a Jihadi prepares for prayer in a bunker
below backward a commander with half a
million dollar Russian bounty on his
head
these chechins are some of Vladimir
Putin's oldest enemies
and Ukraine's fiercest allies
they're fighting a holy war against the
Russians says their Commander Mansoor
and showing them no mercy
I have no pity for them at all because
God gave everyone a brain for thinking
if he is not thinking he shouldn't walk
on the earth he belongs below the ground
they're a sabotage unit improvising
their own weapons afar extinguisher
packed with high explosives as a
rocket-propelled grenade
Allahu Akbar
because
and suicide belts in case they're caught
by the Russians
their base is rigged to blow up if it's
overrun by their enemy
they're all wanted men in the eyes of
Russia and their movement shrouded in
secrecy they rarely allow this kind of
access
we can't show anything that gives away
the location of the chechen's
headquarters to the Russians but we can
say we're in bakmut the front line is
nearby and the battle is going on
constantly
this is our devil machine he tells me
they've adapted an old soviet-era weapon
into a rocket launcher his unit uses to
drop Munitions on Russian infantry in
their trenches
and this is it in action
they've been fighting against Russia for
a Chechen Homeland since the 90s against
Vladimir Putin and the man he installed
as puppet leader in chechnya ramzan
khadirov a man known for callus
brutality and relentless self-promotion
his church and forces are fighting for
the Kremlin in Ukraine
these men those chechens have sold their
souls to Putin
our ancestors didn't spill their blood
just for us now to be bought with a Land
Cruiser
we wouldn't exchange one percent of our
religion and culture for all their
riches they would offer
the shake man saw Battalion have been
Waging War against the Russians in
Ukraine since 2014. oh
but I am engaged in one of the most
intense battles of this war
for control of the town of bakmut where
Russians are sending in wave after wave
of soldiers against them
they're only good in killing civilians
they are sending forward troops like a
cuddle for Slaughter leaving the ground
covered with the corpses they do it
every day they have no pity for their
own people
the ranks of the Battalion have been
increased by Ukrainian converts
if today the war ends in Ukraine that is
we win for us it will not end we have to
fight until that time that we destroy
that Empire of evil totally
that Commander has fought the Russians
for 20 years eight of them spent in
prison they all hope when this is over
they can take the battle to chechnya and
win back their Homeland as the Russians
hinged towards them they plan their next
move but their enemies are for now
destroying the city block by Block in a
grinding War of Attrition neither side
shows any sign of winning Dominic wagorn
Sky News bakmut
[Music]